[Música]
bom dia meu nome é rogério filho e como
andre disse eu vou falar sobre a
criticidade como elemento central para
se pensar e pensar construir e
reconstruir a universidade é bom como
título da minha apresentação disse eu
penso que a criticidade é o elemento
mais importante na formação
universitária e para isso eu preciso
definir o que eu tô entendendo por
crítico porque o termo crítico ele vem
assumindo diversos significados e na
verdade às vezes ele é até mesmo
banalizado
é a gente pode dizer é a ponto de alguns
teóricos até sugerir em abandonar o uso
do termo crítico eu particularmente acho
que a solução não é abandonar é explicar
bem o que a gente está entendendo por
crítico então eu comércio trazendo o
contexto acadêmico que é enfim o
contexto que nos interessa que o termo
crítico no contexto acadêmico
se a gente observar é qualquer livro que
se propõe a ensinar pensamento crítico a
gente vai ver que na verdade eles estão
falando de argumentação
então é uma análise de um sumário de um
livro que esses vai mostrar que eles
estão falando o que é um bom argumento
que não é um bom argumento que é uma
opinião e não um argumento é como é que
se diz é ter fontes confiáveis né pra os
seus argumentos
então não é que isso não seja válido de
forma alguma é extremamente válido
acontece que eu entendo que essa questão
da argumentação ela é o ponto de partida
um pensar crítico não é o ponto de
chegada é ser crítico não é só isso
e aí eu trago aqui é 4 é conceitos
principais quatro formas de se pensar o
crítico que diferente teórico vem
utilizando
então é o primeiro seguia a ideia de um
distanciamento é aquela ideia de que pra
você
consegui entender criticamente o
fenômeno você precisa se distanciar dele
você não pode estar muito envolvido
emocionalmente
então é verdade que faz algum sentido
tem uma lógica isso mas a gente tem que
entender que essa visão de crítico ela
não considera as diferenças
é como se qualquer um é parece muito
fácil né qualquer um consegue se
distanciar e aí a partir do momento que
você se distancia pronto você é consegue
é ter esse pensamento crítico
acontece que a sociedade trabalha com
relações de poder e que esse
distanciamento nem sempre vai ser
acessível a todos
é da mesma forma então eu passo por
segundo conceito de crítico que seria o
de relevância social que vai dizer que
pra você pensar criticamente você
precisa entender o contexto social é
daquele fenômeno claro o mesmo fenômeno
em diferentes contextos vai assumir
significados diferentes
ok isso é faz sentido é coerente
no entanto o crítico não se resume
apenas a isso é essa idéia na verdade
parece uma ideia de conformismo de
adequação
bom nesse contexto é dessa forma nesse
outro contexto então eu tenho que agir
dessa outra forma então você se
readequar sua e você não promove
transformação você simplesmente se a
época se conforma
então a gente à parte o terceiro é
conceito que seria aquele de crítica à
ideologia dominante de novo
é sim é um conceito relevante é existe
muitas vezes e muitas vezes ou sempre
uma ideologia dominante que permeia os
cursos
mas qual é a questão aqui de certa forma
esse conceito acaba simplificando as
coisas
ao dividir a sociedade entre dominou
dominados e dominadores é essa divisão
existe a questão é nem todo dominado
igual nem todo dominador é igual então é
a crítica à ideologia dominante é parte
do conceito de crítico mas não é todo o
conceito de crítico
aí agora a gente parte paga o 4º
conceito é esse conceito é o conceito
com o qual eu mais me alinho toda a
minha fala sobre pensar em uma
universidade crítica tem a ver com esse
conceito de promover práticas
problematizadoras que permitam um
engajamento com as diferenças
bom a gente pode de certa forma dizer
que esse último é conceito de certa
forma abarca os anteriores que são o
distanciamento a relevância social eo a
a crítica à ideologia dominante
então por que porque é pra você se
distanciar
ou quando você é considera a relevância
social ou quando você reconhece a a
dominação e o dominado
você tá se engajado com diferenças você
está reconhecendo que nem todo mundo é
igual
acontece que não é uma uma um conceito
tão direto quanto os anteriores
então quando eu falava de distanciamento
eu atacava um ponto específico quando eu
falava de é relevância social eu estava
focando num ponto específico ao mesmo
pra é é a crítica ideologia dominante
bom
falou em engajar com as diferenças e o
povo é como eu disse abarcando tudo mais
uma forma mais objetiva
eu não ponho do tão direto ao ponto e aí
qual é a crítica qual é o erro que que a
gente pode é se de pagar a questão do
relativismo
pode parecer como eu tô tentando abarca
muita coisa eu acabo caindo na questão
da relativização é digamos que é um medo
que eu não tenho porque relativização tá
aí é isso mesmo faz parte do mundo e eu
quero chamar atenção por a questão do da
escolha das palavras quando eu falo
engajamento com a diferença embora eu
tenha falado que é a banca a questão do
distanciamento e mar em que as palavras
elas são opostas de certa forma
distanciamento e engajamento e aí eu
trago aqui também a ideia de proximidade
e crítica que é a ideia de proximidade
ela está parecida com a de engajamento é
o demonstra bem uma certa oposição à
ideia do distanciamento na medida em que
esse conceito propõe que você não
pretende se distanciar do fenômeno você
tem que se aproximar do fenômeno na
verdade é a idéia de um pesquisador um
mundo que é um pesquisador que atua no
mundo sem se distanciar dele e ao mesmo
tempo ele se um mundo
naquelas questões que ele está
analisando então tudo junto e misturado
num é é não é nada de distância em campo
eles ele mistura naquela lama toda e
vamos ver
é bom dar seqüência a essa ideia de
engajamento com as diferenças que a
idéia de crítico porque eu tô
trabalhando eu trago os estudos cuia é a
palavra corria originalmente é é uma
palavra bem pejorativa
um xingamento na verdade para se referir
a gays e aí é os estudos concluir vieram
ressignificar e se essa palavra e
atualmente a gente tem é considera que
corria é tudo que o discurso da
sociedade transforma em anormal em
estranho em objeto em subalterno a
questão da sexualidade é uma delas mas
também questões religiosas questões de
raça etc é os estudos que ia eles vão
assumir um posicionamento concreto
classificação e padronização
então é é não botar tudo em caixinha é
querer entender cada um fenômeno
particularmente sem é sem querer rotular
nada e contra os pilares - é são os
estudos concluir
eles vão trabalhar com uma teoria
crítica e pós identitária orientada
pelas diferenças não só pela diversidade
e qual é a diferença de diferença e
diversidade é eu gosto de dar um exemplo
tem assim a a gente vê que escolas e
cursos de graduação dizendo que são
multidisciplinares
eu acho bem interessante né o que será
um curso que não é multidisciplinar um
curso que tem uma disciplina apenas
então diversidade é essa pluralidade
aqui existe aí tudo bem é plural mas e
daí
a gente precisa entender a questão da
diferença e não irá realizar essas
diferenças através da transformação
então alguns parâmetros orientadores da
visão de crítico que eu tô propondo aqui
é pegando emprestado alguns elementos da
dos estudos concluir seriam o primeiro a
desafiar constantemente o estudante a
questionar o que é normal
nada é normal porque é que existe um
motivo
aquilo mas a zaga ter sido considerado
normal então que normal é esse tá quente
é normal quem determina que aquilo é
normal ou não
o os a gente precisa preparar o
estudante para isso é porque muitas
vezes essa questão do normal causa
sofrimento das pessoas
quando você não é enquadrada naquilo que
a sociedade considera normal você sofre
é com isso então é fundamental trabalhar
uma educação da justiça social
demonstrando compromisso com a mudança e
ao mesmo tempo perturbando os alicerces
sobre os quais as naturalizações são
construídas para isso é preciso
construir uma base de conhecimento
sólido porque o estudante só vai
conseguir estranhar essa normalidade
se ele tivesse a base de conhecimento
sólida em base de conhecimento sólida
num são é as matérias necessária os
conteúdos teóricos da asma pegas apenas
pensar criticamente os conteúdos é o que
vai fazer é vai dar pro o estudante essa
possibilidade de estranhamento anterior
condições para auto reflexão trabalhando
para a transformação tanto dos
estudantes oprimidos quanto os
opressores ao invés de simplesmente
silenciá los ou adverti los é muito
fácil quando alguém discorda de mim eu
mandar aquela boca ou chamar a atenção
na verdade a questão não é essa eu
costumo brincar com os meus alunos que
eu ensino eles a me questionarem é claro
que não é um questionário de é de
pirraça só questionar por questionar
para desafiar é um questionar bem
fundamentado né aí a gente volta a
questão a da argumentação que a gente
viu antes
mas se o aluno me questiona com
fundamentos
eu fico satisfeito porque significa que
consegui atingir meu objetivo finalmente
manter as expectativas em alta porque é
muitas vezes a gente acha que é anão e
sua tia muito eu não vou é chegar até
esse ponto eu acho que a gente tem que
manter sempre as expectativas em alta a
gente tem que ser o tópico
quanto mais a gente almeja mas a gente
vai conseguir nunca vai se chegar lá no
que a gente almeja então quanto menos a
gente almejava menos ainda a gente
consegue quanto mais almejar mais é se
almeja
só assim a gente consegue de fato
promover transformação então repensando
e reconstruindo a universidade é eu
quero dizer que a gente precisa muito
além dos conhecimentos meramente teórico
que aquele teórico dissociado da prática
ou mesmo muito além dos conhecimentos
meramente técnicos que é aquele do como
fazer mas sei se refletir
eu tô aqui dizendo que os conhecimentos
teóricos e técnicos não são relevantes
eu tô falando que a gente não pode
pensar nele de forma estanque
é preciso criar cidadãos críticos
capazes de promover transformação por
meio do conhecimento então o
conhecimento ele não é o fim
o conhecimento um meio pelo qual os
cidadãos críticos vão de fato promover
transformações é isso obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]